a poco más de un mes desde que el último
soldado estadounidense abandonar
afganistán eeuu está celebrando su
primera reunión en persona con los
nuevos gobernantes del país los
talibanes las delegaciones llegaron a
doha en qatar este fin de semana el
departamento de estado de eeuu hizo
hincapié en que la reunión no supone el
reconocimiento del gobierno talibán
tenemos claro que cualquier legitimidad
debe ganarse a través de las acciones de
los talibanes
washington quiere garantías de que los
talibanes cumplirán su compromiso de
permitir que los ciudadanos
estadounidenses abandonen el país
decenas de ellos todavía están tratando
de salir junto con miles de afganos
elegibles para visas estadounidenses la
delegación norteamericana también quiere
que los talibanes permitan entrar a
ayuda humanitaria mientras el país
enfrenta una severa crisis económica la
reunión de dos días se produce poco
después de un atentado suicida con bomba
en la ciudad de kunduz al norte de
afganistán que mató a decenas de fieles
de una mezquita chií cientos de personas
acudieron a los funerales a despedir a
sus familiares y exigieron protección a
la autoridad talibán
este ataque arroja dudas sobre la
promesa de los talibanes de devolver la
seguridad al país después de décadas de
violencia
les aseguramos a nuestros hermanos
chiítas que en el futuro les brindaremos
seguridad y que esos problemas no les
volverán a ocurrir
a toda la nación incluido en nosotros y
nuestros ancianos está de luto con ellos
verdad el ataque del viernes es sólo el
último realizado por la rama local del
grupo estado islámico los rivales de los
talibanes han intensificado una campaña
de ataques mortales desde la retirada de
eeuu en un intento por desestabilizar a
los nuevos gobernantes de afganistán